first let me welcome he is the host of
life liberty in Levin I call him the
great one Mark Levin is on our newsmaker
line here Mark let's get your reaction
all of this uh 10 indictments that
appears have been uh put in a seal
verdict signed by the judge filed with
the clerk and we expect to hear
according to the clerk it could be any
moment now
sure Putin's proud I'm sure our enemies
are celebrating our allies are appalled
to what's going on here what's happened
here
is and and uh and I want to hit it
pretty well there Congress is supposed
to make all these final decisions you're
not supposed to criminalize
the challenging of electors or dual
collectors or counting of votes and that
sort of thing these are uh these are
prosecutors these are grand juries
um
the legal system the judicial system has
completely been bastardized in these
districts completely
uh we're going through the motions of
Justice here like autocratic regimes
we're going through the motions we have
judges
most countries don't have grand juries
grand juries were set up to help
defendants now they help prosecutors
these are all Democrat cities going
through the motions the Democrat
president the Democrat attorney general
who's been doing a number of outrageous
things
and this is a grave attack on our
Judicial System our system of justice
and our election system and this is an
attack on the Republican Party Don't You
Dare Challenge elections don't you dare
send in other electors don't you dare
question machines don't you dare do a
damn thing because nobody knows what the
rules are in these Democrat cities or
these states anymore
it is horrendous I want to take a little
bit of issue with my friend Jonathan
true
it's not clear in the Constitution
whether you can indict a sitting
president in fact I don't even mention
the reason you cannot indict a sitting
president is because both parties have
agreed under attorney's general of
either Party The Office of legal counsel
that we don't indict sitting presidents
because you will decapitate the
government at the same time the man or
woman in that office is trying to defend
their Liberty trying to stay out of
prison
so in basis of comedy and bipartisanship
it's been decided you don't do that to a
president
I would find it hard to believe that
under article 6 paragraph two of the
Constitution commonly referred to as the
supremacy clause
that any serious Court like the Supreme
Court would say you know what in the
federal court say president cannot
indict himself
excuse me a president can pardon himself
a president cannot be indicted but that
said when local VA they can that's not
going to fly the supremacy clause
established the Constitution and federal
law take precedent over state laws and
even state constitutions and they're not
going to allow State DA's or Local
District Attorneys to interfere with the
functioning of federal elections any
federal presidency it's never been tried
but I seriously doubt they're going to
let a D.A do what the Attorney General
of the United States is prohibited from
doing so let's put that on the table in
Georgia New York number one number two
and I think it was Greg who brought this
up the nature of the statutes that
they're using are so Outlander and so
outrageous and the way that they're
looking for anything to twist any law to
twist any event
to try and take down Trump rather than
leave it to the voters and the fact that
they want these trials immediately
during the Republican primary before the
election should make it so abundantly
clear to everybody what's going on here
the problem is uh sorry Alan that the
Democrat Party has become so radicalized
and such a tool of its Radical Face they
are tonight most of them celebrating
they don't come out and say a damn thing
about Hunter Biden
they circle the wagons
Joe Biden they don't even have a
curiosity about anything related to Joe
Biden despite the fact there are
predicates all over the place for a
special counsel and they are excited
they got bragged they've got this one in
Atlanta they got their Hitman in
Washington DC who's using the wrong
venue for a grand jury use the clan
actors and the Enron laws they're going
to use a RICO statute ladies and
gentlemen
the people of America
you know what's going on here this is
not this is not Justice Just because you
have a judge just because you have grand
juries
just because you have a fake media
that doesn't mean things are going right
you know how many countries have voted
for tyranny
people vote for tyranny and then it's
too late they realize what they've done
you know how many dictators have been
elected at The Ballot Box
and how many people who have challenged
them have been called enemies of the
state
and have been thrown at prison
do you realize that when this this has
been the Donald's maximum sense is just
just
would be facing a thousand years in
prison a thousand years do you realize
how ridiculous this is and how
outrageous it is Joe Biden going on
vacation the Attorney General the United
States that never opens his big mouth
you got people who are self-righteously
saying how wonderful the system is
nobody's Above the Law are you kidding
me
this is a grave time in American history
and Alan it's not for bananas it's full
banana that's what it is and if they
can't figure out how to get this to the
Supreme Court in time which is not a
slam dunk and if the Supreme Court won't
take it out at least put all this
Mischief till after the election the
damage is forever that's my opinion hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else